oh wow
so good wow today's video is sponsored
by display
yeah this is the second time i worked
with them i was so pleasantly surprised
last time i was like whoa this is
actually awesome for those who don't
know display is metal posters they come
in all kinds of different finishes they
have over a million different type of
prints so anything you're interested in
they'll have a version of it let me show
you some of the ones they sent me death
lobe
that will fit my office nice i haven't
played it but they work with some of the
biggest brands as well like witcher fall
out this one is a matte finish i really
like that i recommend checking that out
quite like this one the ship worldwide
it takes about a week to arrive in u.s
and europe they also had some classical
arts which i really like
this is a
greater casper or something it's cozy
that would look nice
yeah that's the thing about this place
it's so easy to swap them out but uh you
might as well suck up and buy a bunch of
them okay love this one hokkaido that
one's gonna replace that one i have over
there just make sure if you use the
larger print to put two of the stickers
i only put one last time i'm supposed to
put two they told me i didn't know
what's really really cool about this
plate is that they have eco-friendly
packaging thank you display for doing
that and also with every print you help
plant 10 trees that's awesome i like
that nice
so yeah check out this plate use the
link in the description so they know i
sent you whatever it is you're
interested in this play will have a
version of a poster for you ships
worldwide so yeah thanks again display
for sponsoring this video really cool
product that i use it's great i
recommend anyway on with the video how's
it going bros my name is piana i am
officially the greatest chef in the
whole world i make the nicest meatballs
there's ever been made very nice to
contrast all the fat and salt
and there you go so let's look at other
people making meatballs making meatballs
by case cooking and today i'm back
cooking again and today
i'm gonna have a try at making
meatballs
i mean also what is this is that this is
like a loose charger cable in the middle
of the wall why is it sticking
you know what
it doesn't matter is that your kitchen i
thought it was a bathroom
they will be when they are cooked all
i'm doing is just getting something
smelling if you can
leave up top and left the camera but all
i'm doing is i'm getting some mincemeat
rather than it i was getting the drink
rolling it in my hands
shut up
[Music]
she doesn't even mixing she doesn't you
have to
you have to mush the meat
you have to mushy
that is not a ball in you no that's not
a ball that's a bunch of strings
together okay are you trying even a
little bit please what are you doing so
italians feel when they butcher their
italian food what is this
what's all the sounds happening this is
like a nightmare the dipping the gooey
bro you can't just take the meat go
dip it
this is illegal what you're doing is
illegal madam you're going to jam i've
got by the way i've got some eggs and
i've beaten them up look it's falling
apart
really out of golden brown
they're too big they're way too big
and
what is that sound she's like witch
brewing something
i was like you don't dip them in egg you
mix egg with the meat and you goo it all
together and then you add bread crumbs
to make sure that it sticks right you
can't no
illegal then
what is that what is that
i am great as you can see there's a
schlub
i have grease patcher it's not normally
that mucky but
don't you dare
me
and i've got i don't know if you can see
but i've also got some
chips cooking
so that's what she's cooking she's
boiling she's frying is that what she's
doing is a proper
chip pan not like the ones that you get
now with all the little handles and
everything
all right i i can't watch this part it's
too repulsive what else could she
possibly do to these poor meat look at
how sad it's just sad i'm just sad oh
she has more she has more how many
goddamn meatballs are you gonna butcher
she's also incredibly slow for being so
sloppy you think it's like ah there you
go no she's taking her time to do this
okay so now there's no more space what
is she going to do look she spilled it
everywhere
why would you spill it everywhere like
that
you didn't need to get it all over the
knobs yes paul that's it oh my word what
should it steam that's because i've been
cleaning it out yesterday like i
normally do
she didn't clean it out such steam how
does that makes
what did you leave inside the oven a
bottle of water
for 10 minutes
wait she cooks them in the oven why
would you
why there's something in there
i just want to tell you something i
don't know if you can hear me over here
does my head in every time i switch the
cooker on it goes off
just to tell you
there might not be some cooking for a
couple of days bro could you not have
shot this somewhat
i don't know if you can hear because the
fire alarm is gone now
but i got a ad read for nordvp
the reason being is that the house is
burning down i understand my cooker top
is cracked
i don't know what happened i just wiped
it down one day and it i just noticed it
will crack ah jesus christ
no
no what happened they all melted
you cannot you are you're going away
madam
which is something i didn't want to
happen
so what i'm going to do is oh
nearly ended up with that ball on floor
so all i'm going to do is
i couldn't make this gross if i tried
this looks like a filthy frank video
what is going on because i'm gonna drain
some of this juice off put them back in
the oven for another 10 minutes
this is gonna be fun trying to turn them
over as you can see they've not stayed
in the yeah she has to turn them over
because she cooks them in the oven and
then only one shape i made
you should usually balls you want to
even
evenly
i can't sir because it ended day
we passed this meatballs
it's not a ball
stop calling in meatballs another
meatballs you get in the gravy
[Music]
as you can see where did all the gunk
come from i understand she likes
lathered it in that egg but man
dude what in that one hell of a time
trying to she's she put some butter or
something she did something foul
well now we didn't see it
oh my lord bro oh my god
ah
you don't have to
what was that
what was that so she she's doing quality
control and for some reason that's where
she drew the line removing the weird bit
of
yellow gunk this can't be real this case
is starting to look a bit like meatballs
they're starting to look a bit like
meatball
no no they're absolutely numb everything
you said it was just a lie stop it i
haven't took any jewels out
what is the juice what is that
so
listen
like i said
but why but why oh my lord they look
quite nice they look quite nice got my
best taste tester to try it would you
please try this what i have got on the
phone it's just come on
yeah i know it's gonna be hot though
isn't it
just take it bit by bit and tell me what
you think please
it should have been they've been in line
here we go a taste test
that's all that matters
[Music]
oh he's joking that's real funny i don't
think anyone can tell the difference
well yes they don't speak to me yes or
no no they don't no right what are you
doing
yeah why don't you try your own goddamn
food
why don't you take a bite she's trying
to kill her husband i don't always eat
my own food you know i don't understand
why i don't understand that a while at
all
you're joking
meatballs
brilliant twists on the classic balls of
meat recipe bellissimo meat brains
dipped in egg i actually feel sick that
makes two of us watching this made me
break my vegetarian lifestyle
mouth watering cake
nailed it now what the heck is this
why does she not mix her mints
so she knows she can mix egg and mint
see in this steak she doesn't have to
dip a rooney what is she gonna do with
it
oh she's put it in
she's changing the game miss me around
it she's making meatballs stabbed by
spaghetti
oh my gosh
oh my god oh my god
oh like that's not gonna cook the
spaghetti it's just gonna burn it
clearly and that's what it did oh my oh
my oh look the light thing is back
i want to die
your cooking might look like it comes
from the dark web but her smile is so
cute i agree she seems like a wonderful
sweet lady
and uh you know maybe they looks really
bad but tastes really good who knows who
am i to judge what i do know tastes good
every single time is geofuel baby check
it out g field link in the description
use code pewdiepie and i'll see you next
video
bye bye oh actually don't subscribe uh
hit the bell notification so you get a
notification and so you know when i
upload do it hit the bell thing